ciao a tutti dal 26 novembre la libertà
con la quale utilizzate internet
potrebbe cambiare
diciamo pure che potrebbe esservi volta
il 26 novembre come regalo per il mio
compleanno il parlamento europeo si
riunirà per una riforma legata
all'articolo 13 del copyright
la riforma dell'articolo 13 sebbene
abbia come punto focale la protezione
della creatività allo stesso tempo
rischia di avere delle conseguenze per
quanto involontario sulla creatività e
sulla libertà di espressione enormi se
la riforma dovesse passare piattaforme
come youtube o qualsiasi altra voi
utilizzate per caricare i vostri video
finirebbero per dover dare priorità a un
piccolo numero di grandi aziende
metteranno presupposto che internet ha
sempre dato la possibilità a chiunque di
esprimere la propria voce creare un
proprio business e crescere nel modo del
lavoro sono le persone reali a decidere
cosa e popolare cosa non esistono e non
devono esistere vertici internet non ha
un palinsesto aumenti po il palinsesto
cielo creiamo lo questa riforma sul
copyright chiede alle piattaforme di
essere responsabili al cento per cento
su quelli che sono i materiali caricati
dalle persone dovrebbero poter
dichiarare che voi avete i diritti di
poter far sentire la canzone che voi
sentite in sottofondo di una storia
dovrebbero avere la certezza che il bene
che voi avete utilizzato non sia coperto
da copyright
la stessa cosa vale per i bit le foto i
suoni i loghi qualsiasi cosa presente
all'interno di un vostro video per
carità la cosa positiva è che la
responsabilità è tutta quanta loro la
cosa negativa è che tutta questa
responsabilità rischia di andare a
nuocere proprio voi
prendiamo youtube ogni giorno vengono
caricate ore e ore e ore e ore di
contenuti che non riuscirebbero ad
essere analizzati da tutti gli abitanti
di manhattan se questi lavorassero 24
ore su 24 per youtube
figuriamoci se riuscissero a fare una
cosa del genere i dipendenti di voi
l'italia per postare un contenuto si
rischierebbe quindi di dover attendere
settimane e settimane di ritardi e
questo solo nel caso in cui si abbia la
fortuna di poter postare ancora sono su
youtube miliardi
video provenienti da tutte le parti del
mondo nord america sud america asia
australia rischiano tutti gli effetti di
essere oscurati in europa sarebbe come
vivere in corea del nord
solamente che in questo caso la censura
verrebbe mascherata come protezione
copyright e per me la legge sul
copyright e sacra su youtube per esempio
esiste già una protezione sui copyright
si chiama contententi il problema è che
in questo modo qualsiasi tipo di video
rischia il blocco per paura di cosa
delle conseguenze spiacevoli di una
svista è impossibile analizzare se ogni
singola cosa è coperta da copyright
quando si riprende la creatività bisogna
difendere di creativi in questo modo le
uniche in realtà che andiamo a difendere
sono aziende potenti che possono
permettersi degli accordi ad hoc che un
ragazzo di 13 anni non può permettersi
ore giorni settimane di lavoro
rallentate o bloccate per la paura che
all'interno dei vostri video ci sia del
materiale che non potete postare esiste
sicuramente un approccio che non vada a
ledere la nostra libertà sono sicuro che
con un mimo i suoi zucca si possa
trovare una soluzione migliore e se
vogliamo fare qualcosa facciamo sapere
di questa riforma che sta passando in
sordina condividete questo video
prendete le mie parole fate le vostre
informatevi su internet
fate in modo che giri questa
consapevolezza utilizzando l'ashtag
savior internet ditelo ai vostri
familiari ai vostri amici alle persone
che vi seguono sul web e che amano i
vostri contenuti affinché tutti sappiano
nell'articolo 13 giu
[Musica]